dans la cage j'ai entendu un petit
déclic à la c'est bon la fraude est mon
eau et là tu as gagné
chaque fois je vous présente jeune alice
voilà bonjour à tous bonjour aux abonnés
de fabien ta chaîne qui est une chaîne
hi tech
voilà je présente des produits tech et
j'essaie d'aller dans le côté un peu à
ce rythme ça veut dire des trucs qui
sortent de l'ordinaire tout simplement
je pense que pour ceux qui me suivent
vraiment peut-être de toi et toi vous
avez remarqué que j'ai à peu près tout
ce qui est geek en permanence google
sommes à un vidéoprojecteur tu as un
imac
surtout qu'il faut modifier ça serait un
peu le matos vidéo c'est assez clair je
ne pouvais pas le voir quelques du coup
on s'en sert alors quelque chose mais
c'est en projet il ya une vidéo que je
veux faire depuis très longtemps sur
cette chaîne j'en avais parlé lors d'une
rencontre abonnés du hac et de la
compréhension des choses mais c'est pas
vraiment dans le cerveau alors qu'il ya
pourtant des mécanismes à connaître
puisque toi qui manipulent des choses
électroniques l'avenir du système
mécanique est pas un puisqu'il s'agit de
ça une serrure transports
c'est exactement ça ou invisibles ça
s'appelle du loch picking ce qu'on va
faire alors le lot picking faut savoir
deux choses je vous le dis tout de suite
c'est interdit de le faire sur des
vraies serrure on n'a pas le droit en
fait de se promener avec du matériel de
l'ocs picking parce que c'est un truc de
cambrioleurs ou de professionnels quand
c'est des serruriers ce soir par contre
c'est un sport à part entière par sport
carrément c'est que c'est un sport ya
les compètes de l'autre picking pour
ouvrir des serrures comme ça des cadenas
etc franchement comme ça on peut voir
comment ça fonctionne et ou au niveau du
système c'est assez cool et ouais c'est
ça qui est intéressant quand je me suis
intéressé le picking est déjà pris en
faire j'avais une quinzaine d'années ça
n'existait pas les cadenas transparent
donc c'était vraiment sur des breaks
annexe à aider fois pour te motiver tu
mettais quelque chose de très important
au bout du cadenas genre
machin c'est complètement obligé de
réussir ta put la clé et a pas le choix
quoi et j'avais appris ça je dis
maintenant il ya presque une vingtaine
d'années puis si dieu mais non tu es
tout jeune avec un sens il ya 19 ans mon
gars au mondial vient de prendre
conscience d'un truc
j'arrête youtube ça va tu as pas trop
les cheveux blancs non ça va ça va ça
c'est la barbe mondiale elle va moi ça
fait un style tu vois ça fait un style
qui s'affairent ch'ti prochaine vidéo je
parle comme le père fouras père noël tu
veux dire ah oui c'est vrai le grand
schtroumpf un mélange d'épreuves et je
me suis dit ce serait cool de parler de
l'ocs picking sur la chaîne je trouve
que c'est pas si éloigné que ça l'aide
du mentalist puisqu'il faut comprendre
le fonctionnement d'une serrure
il faut faire preuve de patience pour
réussir à le faire ce genre de serrure
vous les trouvez sur amazon je mets un
lien dans la description ça coûte pas
très cher ce sont ce qu'on appelle des
serrures d'entraînement et ne le fait
pas sur des vraies serrure merci
beaucoup et pas en prison ça fait des
bureaux sinon voilà pour faire du locle
et qu'il faut donc des serrures
d'entraînement alors celles ci sont
transparentes c'est très bien pour
commencer et aussi du matériel le titre
le petit kit complet alors il ya deux
choses dans le picking il ya ce qui va
permettre de baisser les pistons on va
en reparler tout à l'heure sont tous ces
outils là et la deuxième chose il faut
c'est ce genre de levier en fait de plus
ou moins gros diamètre qui vont
permettre d'appliquer la force qui donne
une clé en fait c'est quand on tourne en
force en fait un accord de faire deux
choses en même temps faut baisser les
pistons et tournait donc avec avec ça en
même temps tu en permanence à appliquer
une force pour que caen s'est libéré ça
tourne moi je faisais ça dans les jeux
vidéo non je ne les ai jamais fait et
par contre j'avais vu une vidéo de la
série et je me suis dit waouh ça tu
attends et du coup je me suis dit ah ça
j'aimerais bien et donc du coup là c'est
de ma surprise c'est vrai oui parce que
je n'avais pas dit ce qu'on allait voir
ça c'est vraiment cool
[Musique]
ça c'est une cette piste on à
l'intérieur d'une serrure qu'il y a donc
tous ces petits pistons là on voit qu'il
y en a sept qui sont eux même poussé par
des ressorts donc ils sont maintenus le
plus haut possible en permanence ça
empêche le bloc de tourner ouais en
effet l'âge et voilà un piston si tu
veux c'est composé de deux parties
distinctes qui peuvent se séparer
j'ai bien réfléchi avant de commencer à
la fin est là et la serrure admettons
elle tombe ici en fait son axe de
rotation ici donc dans ces cas là il
faudrait que le piston il soit comme ça
à la il doit bouger descendent et tu
vois le l'endroit où là on voit le
premier le deuxième piste on a qu'à
petit séparation entre les deux ouais là
vous voyez ça bien et bien notre but
c'est que la séparation a soit bien ce
niveau là d'un co à oreille pour l'autre
pareil pour l'autre pareil pour lui pour
lui pour lui et pour lui donc c'est
extrêmement le premier travail du loch
piqueur mais tout ça tu n'auras pas le
faire c'est cool ça c'est cool
c est ce que je suis quelqu'un qui pas
très patient c'est de travailler à la
règle c'est à dire et c'est rare que les
gens ont des cannes la transparence
devrait se tenir avant et avec ce genre
d'outil là il va enfoncer et compter le
nombre de piston pour savoir combien de
piston il a l'âge en classe 1 qui est
pas très épais parce que j'ai vu que la
serrure était pas très grande
donc il faut qu'ils les pistons il faut
qu'ils aient ça il faut qu'ils outils
que je mette dedans d'accord qu'il faut
pas que je prenne toute la place à
l'intérieur
est ce que je vais t'apprendre à faire
c'est de l'ouvrir avec ça dans une
méthode qu'on appelle communément à la
barbare c'est à dire que comme toi tu
vois ce que tu fais tu vas pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout et commencé à faire ce
qu'on appelle la drac et tu va raquer et
comme tu es en train de mettre une force
en même temps dessus à chaque fois que
le cylindre se décale et que toi tu es
en train de raquer il se place même à qu
il se bloque tout seul en est ce un port
je relâche pas la pression ils sont en
train de se bloquer c'est intéressant ça
nage et le troisième qui est bloquée je
vais le débloquer
voilà on voit que ils sont lâches donc
tout va bien ils sont en place la gamin
qui bouge pas tu vois dans le tas le
troisième quand je fais ça ne bouge pas
ah oui oui le troisième bouche mais ça
veut dire qu'il est encore bloqué donc
là je vais me caler dessus et je vais
être un peu plus insistant sur lui
j'ai entendu un petit déclic à la c'est
bon l'astre l'élément eau et là tu as
gagné et on et jackpot
en tout cas ils sont configurés
exactement pareil et c'est pour ça je
dis c'est quand même assez flippante
c'est à dire à quelle vitesse
tu peux ouvrir un cadenas rapide 0 c'est
ce type de cannes à conques on utilise
par exemple dans les écoles au niveau
des casiers
c'est ça c'est ça et pareil aussi par
exemple pour les cadenas de vélo
quelques mois donc au final si on a
envie de vous voulez vos trucs sans
problème ouf on préfère le coup de main
mais en général les gens qui veulent
voler ils ont kulemin malheureusement
oui
du coup du coup plus facile parce que
cinq listes ont si jamais vous voulez
vous procurer sans entraînement c'est
intéressant ces serrures la
d'entraînement parce que c'est pas les
mêmes cinq pistes en de ce côté que de
ce côté donc tu t'entraînes vraiment sur
deux types de serveurs différents
ok donc même principe tu vas placé là
tout le laissait un tu vas place et ça
au dessus et appuyé alors faut que tu
trouve la boîte pour bien fort se voit
là et après tu vas commencer à marquer
on va voir ce qui se passe ok bon c'est
parti pour nos jeunes
tiens tu sais quoi je vais garder la
pression si tu veux pas ou alors quand
ils équipent mec alors là c'est le
cinquième est du coup assez c'est un
petit peu et oui comme tu as les deux
piquets ce que tu veux changer d'outil
ou à votre dossier avec lui ou avec
liste aux élections et ouais si la ville
de hockey oui mal alors là il va falloir
peut-être ne le dernier lire je vais les
vérifier avant parce que ces cinquièmes
qui aime parce que moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est le cinquième qui est pas très
bien alignés c'est ça que je te paye
classe a sera là et l'indre et de la
bouilloire à temps et voilà exactement
super alors je suis devenu un
spécialiste de cambriolage
c'est trois minutes alors tiens regarde
là on voit bien ce que je te disais donc
on a les pistons et on voit les autres
pistes ont ici là haut qui sont
complètement lâche si je fais ça tu vois
il tomber
et c'est trop marrant comme système je
pensais pas alors j'avais déjà vu des
photos comme ça et jamais vu en vrai
c'est vrai que c'est assez assez
impressionnant ça c est toutes les
scènes découvertes ses erreurs à pistons
sont réglés comme ça mais depuis
toujours en fait face aux autres
visualiser dans les vidéos dans sa tête
était obligé comme quand c'est pas
transparent que c'est normal de mettre
ton outils d'imaginer le nom de c'est ça
quand même
et après au fur et à mesure que tu
débloques et tuchan danse douala et
danse douala de dire ok le 2 il doit
être là il a alors tapé là et à tout un
puzzle en 3d dans ta tête et claque saül
quoi tu vois ça c'est vrai voilà mon
petit chat s'était simplement ça que
j'avais envie qu'on fasse ça va merci
fabien pour cette découverte je voulais
absolument une fois testé ça et c'est
vraiment la belle surprise donc
franchement merci interlace viens tu
veux je te laisse de quoi leur piquer
pencher toi c'est la maison super cadeau
merci beaucoup voilà fabien il est riche
que c'est franchement un petit pouce
bleus pour sa générosité 1-0 il d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous
a plu
si vous voulez qu'on en reparle
différemment sur d'autres types de
serrure est peut-être un peu plus poussé
on peut le faire vous pourrez comble
l'autre vidéo ça sera clair avec un vrai
cas n'a pas transports écoute je dois
monter le parti va ça donc je vais te
confier tout un petit kit d'entraînement
et dc je sais un mois 6 mois ou quoi la
prochaine fois que moi je vais vers chez
toi ou que tu joues tu repasses on se
fait la suite de la vidéo
écoute moi je suis carrément show avec
deux plateaux ce vraiment ça me va ça me
va ça vous va aller de chez qu'est la
chaîne de jojo on
on va faire une vidéo aussi sur ta
chaîne qui va sortir dans les forts
sympathiques c'est assez franchement
impressionnant il a bien géré vous
verrez ça on n'en dit pas plus longue
abonnez vous à mon pote n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner aussi à ma chaîne s'est pas
encore fait vous pouvez mettre un pouce
en l'air et à très bientôt
salut alors si c'est pas encore fait tu
peux aussi s'abonner à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond
que tu vois la justice ici
ce petit rond là ça marche depuis la
tablette de téléphone c'est extrêmement
pratique il n'y a plus de raison
d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool
[Musique]